the horrible shooting in aurora colorado
was tragic obviously but watching some
of the news coverage and following it
online reminded me that i think there's
a fundamental shift going on in the way
breaking news is going to look in the
next decade or so i was thinking about
this because in the minutes and hours
right after the shooting Network News
had no problem turning to social media
feeds of the people who were there and
the guy who they say they think did it
because they didn't have anything else
right they even before they had people
on scene or while they had people just
coming on soon and that's going to
happen more and more right at any given
event people are pumping data into the
InfoSphere about what's going on around
them they're tweeting or they're
checking in various location based
services or they're taking Instagram
photos generating information right but
then they're they're putting that
information in onto the internet into a
place where it could potentially be
scraped so combine that with the fact
that now we can see those locations
because of things like a google map or
Google Earth or any of the other mapping
services or even the high-end
surveillance satellite kind of stuff
that the place like ESRI will have right
so more and more that's almost real time
as well it's updated constantly and we
can see that right so now you have the
the stage set if you will and you have
performers performing because all of
those images and tweets and what not
have time and date stamps and they're
geo-located they they'll have GPS
coordinates so what we're talking about
is a 4d coordinate system on every piece
of information that's coming out of a
given place so now you have information
coming out of a place and you have the
place now there's a conversation going
on in journalism now about how to cover
breaking news whether it makes sense to
have the sort of pulse beat of an
analyst like sitting behind a desk doing
sort of what I'm doing now actually
saying you know this just in with the
head set on or if you set up something
called the stream right where you
basically have like a browser type
interface and you let the user the
person sitting at their computer comb
through every piece of information
stream that they can
I think maybe there's a third way
emerging here if you can imagine you got
to work with me on this some kind of
technology that could scrape all of that
stuff coming off of an individual feed
right and and and mesh it somehow stitch
it together with the the geographic
information so I'm thinking about
something that looks a little bit like
maybe photosynth or similar applications
that'll where you can take a lot of
pictures of room let's say and the
software will stitch those together and
create an immersive environment and
increasingly those environments are
available right like you can actually
get google map type maps inside big
places like Las Vegas casinos so I think
more and more we're going to see every
place around us in like a that'll joke
about the one-to-one map right there's
going to be a map of the real world
ported into the virtual world and you'll
be able to overlay breaking news events
on top of that as they happen so what
I'm predicting here is instead of
waiting for the network news to break
into a TV show you'll actually be able
to have an immersive environment created
by that breaking news event I think that
next time news breaks and hopefully it
won't be something as horrible as what
happened in Aurora we will just be able
to watch it will actually be able to be
there